I've never had a hemorrhoid I have you
have
yep probably when I was like 21. can I
ask a question yeah is the hammer is a
hemorrhoid
on your butthole it's on your butthole
it was like so you know obviously it's a
circle right so it's like on the river I
don't know if that's obvious I've never
seen a hemorrhoid before no a butthole
oh
but
okay okay yeah so it's like it's like a
circle right so it's like kind of like
it's on the rim
and and how did you know did you get a
mirror under there no you can feel it no
but like how did you know what it looked
like did you take a look at it no I just
uh you didn't look at it ever no there
was just one day where I was like I was
I was right before I had to use the
bathroom I was like that
that hurts a weird amount so I I just
did uh I did a field test
and I went I was like I was like oh
that's a bump
and I was like oh that's probably what I
think it is how do you know it's not as
it
is it a one I've never had a zit on my
butthole but I also know what a zit
feels like right and it did not feel
like that have you ever gotten it back
because don't they come back if if you
proceed to keep doing the same things
you were doing what does that mean why
do you know if you push too hard when
you poop oh it's pretty much like it's
pretty much like you know when you push
two if you push too hard prolapse can
happen What prolapses when your
I know what it is yeah so you can't you
can't push too hard when you poop or
else it or else prolapse happen somebody
wait how hard are you pushing were your
complete comes out very like I
assume it happens to a lot of people who
have constipation
zero percent chance
somebody pushes so hard that their
butthole comes in it's probably not all
in one sitting it's if you push too hard
when you poop regularly like if you push
hard every time you poop
you might just hit it your butthole hits
a Breaking Point you know when I those
Pro last you know what they
look like when they come out they look
like that party favor
it looks like the top of an unripe
tomato oh my God yeah but so yeah so
that happens and then uh after that I
I just just had to
you know be more patient did you apply
no nothing no I just let it go away
naturally did it hurt enough where you
were like I would use a leech right now
it's there was there were some points
where I was like yo this is
this just hurts like even like just
going to the bathroom regularly and
you're like not trying to do anything
and just sit there anything that happens
is painful I guess I've never been a
pusher
there's an Alt J song called are you a
pusher or a puller and I think we know
which one you and me are
I'm The Pusher that was the joke oh okay
and you're the puller what's that song
about Pusher puller uh it's actually
it's actually a really like light
melodic song
um it's like are you up like you push
people away or do you pull them closer
oh and are you a pusher or are you a
puller right that's what that song is
about that
some fascinating I never told you that I
had one of those no talked about
everything man I guess that's one of
them that we haven't
and the more you know let's find a leech
person nope
not a single chance I'm good now don't
get me in don't put you're not putting
the leech anywhere near my butthole